the early Rogan days were [__]
fascinating because
you know when you talk about Tosh doing
radio that was all we really understood
and Joe was not having it so when you
tried to do bits he would shut it down
my first Rogan appearance it would be
cool to see a highlight reel of me
trying to do bits on him because I was I
was like oh yeah because I didn't know
what no one knew what a podcast was
right especially the way Joe does it you
I would be interested to Club them out I
was like I fought a bear one time and he
was like
what uh what what region was the bear
from and you're like um
I thought
I don't know what region it was from and
he was like well wait why would you and
it was like very thoughtful conversation
and then you real I realized I realized
within 20 minutes this is not radio yeah
and so
and I realized that the best thing you
could do is listen to Joe sometimes yeah
to try to respond to him yeah it's why
today I don't feel like I'm that great
when I do Rogan because it's it's a lot
of it I feel like I'm just catching up
with a friend and I don't know if it's
entertaining as a podcast I feel like
you're just hanging out with your buddy
well maybe that's the camaraderie people
want maybe they're alone and maybe
they're working from home they haven't
seen anybody that day
about it I used to love it so I get
offered to do Rogan I remember saying to
Ari
because I didn't trust celebrities I had
gotten in a fight with a I gotten in B
for the comic and I just didn't trust
and I said Ari and Redman I said so like
what's what's with Joe's thing is he gay
and they're like I was like I thought he
was gay because I was like why would he
wanted me to come to his house and like
what's his deal and like no he's just a
great guy I go no no no no no no they
all got something what is it and then
they're like no he's just a good guy he
thinks you're funny like do his podcast
so
oh yeah I thought everyone was gay I
thought Elliott Gould was gay anyone
Will Smith I thought Will Smith this guy
anyone that wanted to be friends with me
I just figured they were gay and they
wanted to [__] me yeah and so I
literally was like went to his house the
most likable guy on the planet you can't
fathom that somebody's like I'd like to
just be around you and like tell stories
they just want dick yeah and but I was a
fan of Joe's I was like a legit fan of
jokes and so I go out to his house I do
the the worst thing you could ever do
when you meet Joe now I know this okay I
go
hey man huge fan I want to meet your
dogs I want to see your deprivation tank
I want to get how I want to play pool
and then we can do the podcast and Joe
is like uh
okay so he takes me out and introduces
his dogs uh we get high we play pool
shows me his deprivation tank meet his
wife meet his kids do a podcast and and
I'm I'm trying to do bits and it's not
working and then I'm like okay and then
I just go into like just going if you
ask me a question I'll respond to the
question which is like what we do now
but it just was not what happened in
media and so uh
I wish people knew what early Radio Days
for Comics were oh because that what
you're explaining makes so much sense
Comics Unleashed yeah where the guy the
comics just go around and do their bits
in a circle that was radio they tee you
up with the premise of your joke I did
Bob and Tom back in the day and you had
to write out your bits you had to write
them out yeah yeah that's why I wrote
out all my bits and then you gave them
to him and like so uh
you ever go to Russia yeah I hear you uh
you're I'm married you married Bert and
you'll be like uh here we go and so but
it was Bob and Tom was fun back and that
was all you knew yeah
so and this is Rogan you do it in an
office I think he had a cat
that would like take shits in the
bathroom in the middle it was in his
office and and Joe was rich but he
wasn't Joe Rich today like Joe was like
and then and he would have you do this
Vlog after the podcast which is so
awkward like Brian will pull out his his
laptop and go all right and Joe's like
what's up I just did a great podcast
with bird suburt what's going on and
he'd be like not much Joe it was so
[__] bad you can find those clips I'm
sure and Joe had black facial hair and
he still had hair he still had hair but
he wore his hat backwards because he's
whatever
[Music]
done the podcast and then he'd be like
you want to go get something to eat and
so like it was like it was crazy you
know he was also banned at the store at
the time yeah that's right so like he
would do shows at the ice house so then
uh so the first time I do it I I think
in my head this is not what I thought it
was going to be I can't do bits here but
I do have that this Russian mafia story
that I bet would be good on this show
because and so I go hey man next time
I'm here remind me to tell you the
Russian mafia story like a week [__]
later he's like hey come tell the
Russian mafia story she's like I'm I'm
sure I'm off on timelines but I come
back I think a week later and he's like
everyone's wondering about this Russian
mafia story and I tell it and I gotta be
honest with you it bombed yeah it like
it it sometimes
I hope I'm not pulling the veil back too
back sometimes Joe and red band will be
fighting
and so you'd go in to do the podcast
there'd be some tension and the whole
thing would be them just Joe being angry
at Red Band because red band is saying
buttholes and Olive Garden the whole
time and Joe's like Brian you got to
realize people are [__] listening to
this and then you just be sitting off to
the side like watching them go back and
forth and then be like duh you guys want
to try some Alpha brains whether this is
when Joe's launching Alpha Brain this is
when they're launching on it right so
he'd give you the the vitamins he load
you up with his vitamins give you a
Fleshlight and then be like take those
Alpha brains tell me what you think
about them and then you take them and in
a real scientific way because they they
promoted uh uh what's the lucid dreaming
uh and so you and and I I'm an active
Lucid dreamer to begin with so you'd
come back and he'd be like you took
Alpha Brain and this would be on the
podcast and you'd be like you'd be like
yeah and he'd go sweet what did you feel
like he you know the Joe analysis part
of his brain and he'd do that on the
podcast about his own own pills because
he was trying to figure out if he liked
him and he's like I love the Alpha Brain
I'm taking like nine a day ago I took
one girl I couldn't sleep and he was
like no what did you take the cortisone
mushrooms the uh roll on roll off
whatever the [__] it was like it was
really uh it was really interesting and
then the the first time I did Rogan I
remember getting in the car and I had 3
000 Twitter followers extra and I was
like I was like Wow second time I did
Rogue and I told the machine story and I
went to the club and it was sold out
comped but sold out
and then and then I watched it and and I
and then the third time I did Rogan I
made a machine shirt the machine shirt
that I I saw the shows I got home to my
house and Leanne goes the [__] we just
sold 25 000 worth of t-shirts she goes I
don't have those made woke up the next
morning she goes we sold 90 000 worth of
t-shirts in like two days we had made
six figures in those t-shirts by the end
of the year by like in three months if
we did that must have been in November
by the end of the year we made six
figures in those machine shirts Joe wore
it at a weigh-in
huge [__] spikes huge [__] spikes
I go to I go to different countries I
remember it was in an Amsterdam and they
were yelling the machine in Amsterdam
and I was like what the [__]
and then uh
I mean so so it's funny
you'd just get high and talk for three
hours and not remember any of it yeah at
all and uh it's crazy to see where he is
today and like I just did it the other
day and I'm like
this doesn't it doesn't make sense to me
that I remember I remember did it one
time and I got really [__] up and I
might have said that America created
covid or something I don't know what I
said who [__] knows what I said
I don't know I'm terrified that's Joe
some regrettable stuff on your podcast
no it was it was great man it's great
I'm bummed that you guys didn't get to
experience that side of the show yeah
because it was the fun when like Joey
Diaz like we just one of the hardest I
ever laughed is Joey Diaz just rolled I
never met him so my this is the opening
words of meeting Joey Diaz
we're doing we used to do death squad
nights at the ice house we're like it
was like nine com five comics on the
podcast with Joe and we just do it and
we do a show and so we'd hop on and off
so we'd go in and do a set and then come
back to the podcast everyone be [__]
up and Joey Diaz comes in I never met
him and he's like
he's a dog
you ever eat a baby eat a woman's [__]
on a quaalude and I was like no and he
goes Lucy snore Bush and we oh you have
a break into someone's house and eat
their [__] on a quaalude Lucy snore
Bush and we tried [__] laughing and
and then it's the hardest I've ever
[__] laughed and one of the top five
hardest I've ever laughed and Joe goes
you've never met Joey before and I go no
and he goes well you're about to be your
best friend and Joey Diaz and I from
that day on Joey lives right around the
corner for me if we ever did that show
we drive out together those were the
days man I miss those days so much
because you would it was so
it was like you guys don't understand
when Comics hated each other they used
to hate each other Comics hated each
other no one wanted anyone to describe
yeah yeah and I think that's still
existing yeah yeah you did yeah you did
yeah I think this still exists but I
think that you guys did something that
really transformed the way that we
behave with one another and it's like
it's pretty awesome that's Joe I mean
well it trickles down man I always say
that like what Joe does for you guys for
me it's like what we do made for other
people but I remember before I met you
you tweeted about bring back a poo and I
just thought that was so [__] cool
that the machine is tweeting you know
this is a great special everybody go
watch it well yeah but I have a it's the
same thing that makes me say I'm lucky
instead of talented is I have I love
being a fan of [__] I've said this ad
nauseam yeah but I like liking stuff
yeah it's I don't understand the energy
of disliking stuff I don't understand
that energy at all of like hating things
yeah I love liking stuff and this makes
comedy so this business so much more fun
to be a fan of your friends yeah and to
love
it was so much fun when you did uh when
you put out Infamous it was so much fun
to celebrate your success
it was so much fun
if you're a fan of it yeah yeah and as
opposed to an as opposed to and I'm sure
those Comics are out there I do not hang
out with them the guys that are like
[__] Schultz [__] Schultz you know that
that's [__] or you know whatever all
that stuff it's so much fun to go look
at this it's changing the game oh [__]
yeah oh it's on YouTube was it a [__]
13 million 15 15 million it's imagine if
you get to pick a team
I want to be the guy that has fun or the
guy that goes to bed angry every night
yeah I'm never gonna pick the angry guy
these guys could make a living doing
that there are guys online that make a
living doing that yeah I want to be the
guy that goes [__] yeah by the way I can
celebrate the guys that hate me also
because I go that's got to be cool to
hate me yeah I get it yeah I get it
trust me
what a [__] weird
episode I've never done a podcast like
this in my [__] life